one of the reasons i wanted to come in
and talk to you was because
i want to just talk freely how does that
all feel for you personally that thought
that one week earlier we could have
saved 21 000 lives there were some
mistakes that we made in terms of the
measures yeah how they were brought in
well now you see stephen you're getting
into gotcha questions no genuinely just
all total rubbish no no no no no no no
no no no i've not even asked the
question yet there needs to be
boundaries you have to go no those rules
yeah were not in place can i ask the
question you can ask a question i'm
going to ask you a question this bit is
really hard for me people say you were a
contradiction yeah what's your response
to that
[Applause]
could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
when i started the diary of a ceo i
wanted to create a platform where we get
to see behind the scenes where we get
the truth where we get the context that
is at least my attempt the rest of it is
up to the viewer to decide what they
make of the conversation and what they
take from the conversation and the same
applies to this episode
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the dire ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
matt
i was really really keen to have you
come and join me in my in my kitchen
here in in london to talk in a long-term
way about a ton of different things that
are front of mind for you that have gone
on over the last couple of years i think
you know usually and you've listened to
this podcast before so you know i
typically start about with childhood and
all those things which i will get on to
but the question that was really front
of mind for me yeah and i think will be
for a lot of people is why did you want
to have this conversation here
well i love your podcast
one of the reasons i love it is because
i think what you managed to do is you
managed to
get people to be really um really honest
about themselves right one of the things
i admire about the podcast is that
it's important
that we have a space where people can
talk about where things go well and
where people have failed and what
they've learned from that
and you're so um
sort of brutally honest with yourself
about it and you really put that on the
line
and that in turn gets it out of other
people and you know i've been through
this
extraordinary experience of being the
health secretary in the pandemic
there's a lot of
you know things that i've learned
through that and learnt about myself
and
i i want to be able to articulate how i
saw it if you like
i just think that you're it's just one
of the most self-aware podcasts that
i've
i've listened to and now i'm completely
hooked
so let's start then i was brought up in
a happy loving complicated modern family
yeah explain
and why complicated well complicated
because my parents separated when i was
two
and i effectively grew up with four
parents
so the both of them
happily remarried before i can really
remember
so it was complicated in the way that
lots of modern families are complicated
and i have
i have a half brother i have step
brothers and sisters but it was also it
was also very
it was very loving and ever you know
that i got that
that love and support from from four
parents rather than the normal two what
were you like in school well one of the
biggest things that happened to me was
that i
i after primary school primary school's
in this lovely um very rural cheshire
uh primary school
very very
straightforward small
warm
and then at the age of 10
they put me in for the or i was asked if
i wanted to go in for the exam for the
local independence school a year early
this was a
probably one of the biggest things that
happened in my childhood
because yeah i went and did the exam and
i got through and i went to school so i
went to secondary school a year early
suddenly i went from being finding it
all pretty straightforward
to really having to struggle to keep up
really having to work hard and both
socially and academically suddenly i was
in this
you know i was in with a group of big
group of people who were all
a year ahead of me and combine that with
my sort of my mother's worth work ethic
you know she started her own business
and worked incredibly hard
and um
you know that had it had a it had a big
impact on me in what way
specifically on the social side you said
yeah socially struggling to keep up were
you bullied
um
a bit i wouldn't say that was the ma
that was the main thing but i was but
yeah people it was tough people were
tough on me um
and
um
and i'm also quite sort of you know
self-confident and exuberant and that
sometimes has rubbed people up the wrong
way especially when you're the little
guy at school
so i think you know that so that i'm i'm
sure that part of the sort of
the drive that i have
comes from the fact that i found myself
age 10 suddenly in a very
you know a tough environment and you you
ultimately must have done pretty well in
that secondary school where you were
trying to figure out because you went to
oxford which is just yeah so i went to
oxford a year early you know so i was
you went to yeah
got into second year
exactly and you studied politics
philosophy and economics right which is
a lot of a lot of people that go on to
become politicians yeah study that
course that seems to be almost like a
bit of a right of passage to
politics in a way because you've got you
know people like is ed miliband david
cameron jeremy hunt that of all yeah
study the list goes on michael go davey
right
um
yeah so one of the things that as being
a bit of a pot like a i guess there's
two questions here the first is why did
you choose politics i thought it was
just i thought it was the most
interesting thing to do i actually got
into it through the economics so i did i
started economics a-level because i was
really interested in business right and
what what happened was this that
um when i was a teenager in the early
90s
my mom's business
nearly went bust
and we had a moment when we had this
uh our major client
themselves was struggling in the
recession in the early 90s
and couldn't pay their bills so it was a
classic late payment cash crunch for a
small business
we knew that if we didn't get this check
by the end of the week then the company
was was going under
eventually on the wednesday or thursday
the check arrived and the business was
saved it went on to to prosper but that
made me ask this question you know
how come a perfectly good business
employing a load of people who are
working incredibly hard
how can that go
bust or be at risk of going bus for
something completely outside of their
control
and
the sort of sense of injustice in that
made me then ask how does the economy
work and that's what led me to
take an interest in economics which i
had a real affinity with i loved it as
an a levels subject and that so that's
what led me to
to um
to ppe
at that age say like 18 19 20 yeah were
you were you aspiring to become a
politician no i was inspiring aspiring
to become an entrepreneur right so i
actually i almost did economics and
management at oxford and then somebody
told me it was easier to get into ppe
than economics and management so and
that sounded close enough to what i
wanted to do right so that's why i ended
up doing it
is there not because because when i
because people have said to me you know
i've had business success and all these
things i've got a platform people say
have suggested oh maybe you should go
into politics steven the thing that
scares the life out of me is yeah it's
like a lose-lose game people are going
to [ __ ] hate you regardless of what
you do so i i sometimes wonder i'm like
who are these people that like yeah want
to be politicians so
well thanks um the um but it's true
right my experience as health secretary
is as you get you know some people uh
are
some people love you and some people
hate you right i was i was on the tube
and i never know what that what what how
it's gonna be when they come from series
so i was on the tube last night um and
some enormous guy in a heavy metal
t-shirt long hair comes up to me and i'm
like oh how's this gonna go
and he said i just want to say thanks i
got my vaccines because of you and i'll
never forget it i was like oh well that
went that could have gotten worse
and so and so you you know and and
obviously not every interaction is um is
cheerful to put it diplomatically and so
in a way you know
that is part of it you know that if
you're going to make a big decision that
affects lots of people's lives some
people are going to like it and some
people aren't and that isn't what got me
into politics what got me into politics
was the observation
that
that's where the big decisions are made
and quite rightly in a democracy you
know the big calls in economics to stop
other people going through the same
experience that i did as an early
teenager with my parents business where
it almost went bust for something
completely outside their control and
that and that and that's what drove me
and the combination of the interests and
you know because it's very interesting
politics
and the mission
uh got me there um so
one of the things that has also always
leveled the like political system in our
country is that and you kind of see this
from you know you studied politics
philosophy and economics at oxford yeah
is that a lot of the people that do go
on to make those big decisions as you've
described yeah they come from like
privilege right right and even you know
you you know your parents went through a
tough time but living in cheshire is
yeah i'd rather live there than moss
side right yeah it's a it's a privileged
place to to grow up and to live and
going into an independent school you
went to king's king's school
king school in chester as well which is
a privileged place to come from yeah so
one of the things that i've always
contended with and is you know and
honestly one of the things that actually
quite quite honestly put me off ever
going into politics was this prospect
that it's kind of this
elitist club where they all come from
oxford and and then the problem you have
with that if that is true right is
that the decisions then that are made
for all of us yeah are made from people
that have walked a different set of
foots yeah path
okay so i think there's a few bits
let's park the oxford point because
actually if we get if oxford and
cambridge and the other top universities
get it right then actually they are
great
um meritocratic levelers
because the thing that oxford really did
for me not only taught me how to read
and write but it also it took a
provincial boy from cheshire
and put him into exactly the group that
you'd describe right so i was from a
very much a middle class background but
if those the the top universities get
their their selection right who they
choose and if they get the
support right so that people from your
sort of background feel encouraged and
drawn towards them and then supported
once you get there then they can be
great levelers okay so so but let's park
the sort of oxbridge debate because
that's the sort of um
that debate will go on for as long as
those universities are preeminent i
imagine i think the most important thing
in politics is where where you're going
and what you're trying to achieve
and one of the most important skills
that i think is incredibly hard to
communicate in politics but is vital to
doing the job well is empathy
right and
you can't
walk
other people's
um
uh shoes except through empathy
and and
you the lived experience of a particular
background is incredibly important and
i'm i'm a you know i'm a big fan of
welcoming people trying to get people
into politics from all sorts of
backgrounds so i'm not disagreeing with
your critique the point is each and
every one of us has our own background
the way that you can try to get over the
problem that you describe
is through
empathy and that's and that's incredibly
important i can't have empathy for what
it's like to be a woman for example
because i've never been one no that's
not true you can have empathy for it but
so yeah i can have empathy but i i
i believe that empathy comes real real
true empathy for someone else comes from
understanding the pain or struggle or
situation they're going through yeah and
i can never truly understand the pain or
struggle that say for example a woman
facing discrimination yeah when she's
trying to raise money right is going
through because i have never experienced
that so i can guess what it might feel
like it's like almost like the topic of
racism i think like yeah no one can know
i don't know how a
white male politician that's gone to
oxford will know what it's like to be
called the n-word on the playground when
i was 11 and how that made me feel like
the feelings of shame and being
different that i then went on to feel
yeah so so i i tend to believe that the
way we create a truly empathetic
political system yeah is by finding a
way to get people in i've come from like
low economic housing and different
backgrounds and minorities so when i
look at
the political landscape and i see that a
lot of you know a lot of people have
come through a very
like too many people have come through a
very privileged background it makes me
think that the decisions that are going
to go on to be made will lack that true
understanding of what it's like to grow
up in a house that is like
damp and moldy and there's rats and
stuff so the there's this i'm grinning
because there's two ways to answer this
right but the thing that's absolutely
screaming at me to say to you is that is
why you should go into politics but i
feel like i can't get in because of
course you can get in you'd be you'd be
i'll sign you up now it depends which
party you want to join that's uh i i can
only speak for one of them but go for it
so firstly that's my actual response but
the other thing is it's it is wrong to
say that you cannot um
uh
that you can't empathize with with
others and others situations you can't
have lived somebody else's life
but you can
seek to try to um to understand where
they're coming from and and i certainly
do that and you know that's part of
representing
a constituency i think it's actually
really hard to communicate in politics
uh this this the empathy point because
it's really easy to generalize um and
and it comes down to the fact that if
you poll people right most people think
that politicians are useless but when
you name a politician they tend to think
that their their their local person
their local mp they tend to think that
they're great right so there's a gap
between what people think of politicians
as a whole and think of individuals who
they've interacted with yeah yeah i
think i think i think i can definitely
definitely
empathize with pain and suffering and
all of those things i just think in
order to create a truly like
representative political system sure it
needs to be full of people who have
actually gone through those things go
poster
get involved i think the thing that
always put me off is because when i
heard about this like you know
everyone's come you know a lot of
politicians have come from a certain
background and then you see how
promotions and stuff are done it makes
me think that it's a bit of a like uh
you know
a system where we're promoting our
friends and bringing them up and if
they've gone to oxbridge and i went you
know i studied with them i'll promote
them when i get there so i one it's
always felt to me like
running would be very very very
difficult
um because i didn't go i don't come from
that sort of privileged oxbridge
like typically quite boys club place
yeah that's how it feels right for me so
it might be wrong i think i i really
think you're wrong because i think
actually the system in a way
um
because of this problem
um the system is actually tries to draw
people through faster
um is it doing a good enough job uh just
i mean look at actually um give miss
credit you know
look at who
boris johnson has put in his cabinet
right and um i know that you're
immediately thinking of people he was at
the same school in university as right
um but there are an awful lot of people
who weren't right and i don't want to go
through the individual backstory of you
know the guy who arrived age nine from
uh kurdistan with only a his dad with
only a pound in his pocket yeah right um
sajid javid who grew up in one of the
poorest streets in bristol and made it
uh from there and by the way who's from
a family of amazing amazing uh men um
his i think he's got four brothers
there's five of them um
uh
uh rishi sunak right he grew up in a his
his mom's a pharmacist he grew up in a
pharmacy right there there are loads of
people who have made it from difficult
backgrounds and and
actually
i'm sad that you have the impression
that that you do because it's not really
my experience of
uh of of being there so you you make the
decision then to move towards politics
you become eventually george osborne's
chief of staff
in two thousand and
nineteen twenty nine and five-ish yeah
yeah and in 2010 you became the mp for
mid suffolk west suffolk west okay
and that that was your
i guess your your entry into politics
yeah
moving forward then you you know you get
promoted a few times and then theresa
may comes in and
demotes you yeah
yeah so she demoted you to minister of
state of digi
digital culture digital and culture and
god that was a brilliant job i mean so
why did she demote you
she demoted me because
they decided they wanted a uh a clean
break
from the cameron osborne years she
didn't like george
well she fired him pretty brutally
and i was just you know head below the
parapet enough to get through
and she demoted me i was i was attending
cabinet at the time and
um she i remember the meeting was um
they had told the press that they were
going to fire people until 11am and then
start hiring people and i was asked to
go and see her at 10 50. so i thought oh
this isn't going to go very well i
walked in and i was
she'd been running about 15 minutes late
so i walk in and there's a clock on the
wall in her house comes off and it says
1105. and i said oh it's gone 11. so i
guess this is going to be okay
and because i thought well you know at
least make a laugh if she's going to be
firing me you know why why make it
unpleasant and she said well that
depends how you react
because um i uh there isn't a space for
you in my cabinet
but i know you're really interested in
digital
and
that's one of the big things that's
going on in the world
so would you like to be the uh the
number two
uh in dcms and
uh and and be responsible for digital
policy and just keep your head down and
sort and um and sort that out
and
i i left it it was absolutely wonderful
this is maybe a bit of my political
naivety but when i when i was reading
through that you'd be you'd been the
minister for like digital business
enterprise energy and ultimately health
yeah
how can one person know anything about
any of that stuff
how can anyone be a master of like five
six different things yeah because that's
not the job so um it's not the job to be
the master in a way it's the job to be
the people's representative amongst the
experts so your job as the minister
is to be able to be the representative
of
the people
who is responsible for the direction of
that policy area and you have endless
experts
your job is not to be an expert is to
listen to the experts and then decide
democratically what direction do we want
to go
so take i mean an area that i do know
you know i did have a background in take
on um the future of the internet
and um what was your background in that
uh well only that i i you know i can
code and i understand a bit of um about
technology
but the big question was how do you keep
children safe online right
and
how you make take the internet from a
sort of a wild west in social media to a
place where people have more protection
you know is it that was the
the the
you know most important question in that
area at the time and for that yes you
need experts but you also need uh you
basically need a view of where you want
to get to it's a it's you want to you
you need to set the mission and the
direction it's let's talk about the
leadership that's needed my background
social media and i actually whenever i
see like the social media policies being
set i always the debate we have in
social media and digital is like who is
it that's making these decisions because
the people we see yeah when we see
obviously the spokespeople as you've
described yeah we know that they don't
know it like us yeah so we think that we
we we pray that the decisions aren't
made poorly so let's take because that
can be the subject we use to describe
all of these industries that you've led
as minister so
as it relates to say social media when
you're trying to understand what
policies to set for children to keep
them safe yeah you're telling me there's
this like group of experts behind the
scenes yeah who are discussing and
feeling information yeah and then your
role to play is in
deciding on the trade-offs the
trade-offs yeah right which would which
needs expertise to know what the
trade-offs are yeah yeah
um and then also
and communicating them communicating it
to the public and understanding what the
public
is expecting okay sometimes experts can
get so close to their subject matter
that you've got to be like yeah but
there's you know there's 60 million
people over there who aren't experts and
they
need the voice
as well yeah you're ultimately the
person when you're in charge of digital
that is making these calls so you speak
to the experts then make the calls
my thing is on a topic like digital the
harm that can be done if someone doesn't
understand that area of expertise
because ultimately the minister makes
the call yeah you can like destroy an
industry [ __ ] and like [ __ ] an
economy so i've always thought that the
person making the call yeah should be
should be really experienced in that
subject matter and that doesn't seem to
be the case because of the design of the
political system because of democracy
student it's democracy and that's good
and right right because when you have
technocratic government
you can you just get people you know
experts are so focused on their area
that sometimes they just don't see the
big picture so you're saying that
impartial kind of outsider to yeah
that's what that's what i tried to be as
a as a as a minister um and also so it's
about lifting people's eyes to the to
the the you know the big social
trade-offs and i mean that in the best
sense that you know the trade-offs
within society um how free to be versus
uh how safe to be in the in the internet
it's an absolute classic of political
philosophy right and people have been
worrying about that question in the
offline world for 300 years and we were
bringing that sort of
approach
um into the online world as opposed to
just leaving it as a completely
libertarian space
um but the the job is to is to
synthesize the expert view but not just
not just follow it
the experts can become so
focused but also they can't sometimes
provide the leadership
right to say we we're going over there
and and you know like yes of course
we're going to take on
um
facebook over some of the harmful
content yeah of course we are we're not
just gonna lie down and
say that they can make the rules up
it's interesting because when i see the
political debates with things like
facebook
a lot of the government officials both
here and in the us haven't got a [ __ ]
clue what facebook is and you can see
them asking mark zuckerberg the most
dumb naive questions about the platform
and then as an outsider watching yeah
that these people that don't understand
what they're talking about are
ultimately going to be writing the
legislation as someone that works in the
industry and could actually tell you
what in my view having worked in the
industry for 10 years deep in it yeah
fully understands things like the
cambridge analytica scandal and data
data privacy and really also understands
the context of the media pressure yeah
which is sometimes
uh comes doesn't come is it agenda based
um
get it right so getting a rational
solution out of that bundle of problems
yeah is not easy yeah so what would you
it kind of isn't it but it is demo but
it but it is democratic
to ensure that somebody who is who
represents um represents people
is ultimately making the decision
but if they're any good they'll listen
to the advice that you get i think i
think my view is that they should
represent the people for sure and i
think that spokesman role in leadership
is incredibly important but i also feel
like they should like have deep
understanding of the nuance and
complexity and have experience in the
thing which kind of brings me on to you
became in charge of health as well yeah
the healthcare which is obviously
something not in your wheelhouse no so
i'm i'm a um doctors asked me you know
why should a non-doctor
be responsible for the health service
now two answers to that first is well
it's pretty arrogant of doctors to say
it should be a doctor what about nurse
right because there's more nurses in the
nhs and doctors park that minor local
issue right
the reason is because i am there as the
representative not just of those who
work in the health service
but of the people who use the health
service which is to say all of us
and so i think actually it's better for
the health secretary to essentially be
somebody who is a who is there on the
side of the patients
you of course you listen to the
the clinical advice you know and some of
the most amazing
brains in the world right like like
chris whittie jonathan bantam
these people are amazing wonderful
communicators
very shrewd advisors
ultimately
it's right that the person taking the
decisions
is representing the people through the
democratic process we have
um and not representing
the uh the producers if you like that is
a that is a better way of structuring it
you you believe that because i really do
i mean i look i i don't know these
issues deeply enough to to know the full
complexities and this is maybe even
proving my point that i don't understand
the nuance of politics so i can't
actually say if that's a better or worse
system
one would assert though that
the best solution might be to have
someone who understands the side of the
patients because they are one we're all
humans we all live in this society so we
use the nhs that gives me a little bit
of empathy as to the the you know the
the
the system from a patient's perspective
yeah but also someone that understands
health and yeah and the nuances of that
maybe that's spent the last 10 or 20
years out you know working within the
industry and can understand those layers
you know more than someone who was
working in digital five minutes ago can
i it's just an observation as like a
naive outside yeah like look it's
yeah it's quite a common um it's quite a
common critique of politics
um and different countries deal with it
different ways right so some countries
the entire cabinet is made up of people
who aren't in parliament
like you know the u.s
cabinet is made up of people who who
have to by law not be in the senate or
the house of representatives but then
you get even more of a divide between
the sort of political
and and the democratic over here yeah
and the essentially technocratic over
there actually i think that our system
is better than the u.s system because
it's because these two things are
emerged together um because you do you
get in taking these decisions you get
incredible
advice you get access to you know the
all the industry experts that you want
to talk to and and
ultimately you're making you know you're
making balanced judgments the way the uk
does it as well is the civil service
will never put forward a proposal that
they don't think is workable that's that
that's the deal right so you do have
these long-term uh experts who have been
in in the field um and they will uh
they'll say okay this is uh the way i i
tried to do it was i'd say this is where
i think we need to get to how should we
best get there and then the experts will
come up with a plan of how to get there
okay and you know you might have a view
on some of the details of that but
essentially i saw my job as saying this
is the mission and then communicating
how we get there and then being advised
all the way from a to b because the the
thing you lose if you go for your model
is you lose the democratic input and
um
and that can lead to things going wrong
in 2019 when theresa may stepped down
you ran to be the next prime minister or
at least to lead the party right well
and that would lead you to being the
prime minister yeah um
why did you want to be the prime
minister
because i thought that there was a need
for a complete fresh start did you think
you'd win no
at least you're honest yeah
no but i i had fun trying
um
[Music]
no i didn't i didn't think i'd win um
but i wanted to get some
i wanted to get some arguments made
right i worried that
my i worried that we were the party was
talking not enough about how it's
enterprise that leads to prosperity is
it a publicity thing running because
they i watch the u.s elections every
year i'm obsessed with it and it and the
same people run every year they know
they're not going to win but i think the
the exposure and publicity you get is
incredible yeah there's a of course um
that's one of the consequences i
basically had an argument i wanted to
make which was which was okay brexit
decision has been taken
uh let's get that done
and get on to building a stronger
economy in the future and basically get
it done as quickly as we can and move
forward that was the argument i wanted
to make i managed to make the argument
quite sort of loudly because i was
running
um and then um
well and then i pulled out pulled out
came seventh got behind boris
was it mm-hmm did you come seventh out
of ten was it
six or seven yeah and then you got
behind boris and then i got behind boris
um because you knew he would win yeah it
was obvious that he was going to win
also
i came to the view that
um he
he could sort the problem that we were
stuck with at brexit better than any of
the other candidates
um and
also i thought you know
this guy has
great capabilities
and he needs
people around him
i've had so many people tag me on
instagram even on telegram and in my
twitter dms in a picture of them
starting their heel journey and it's one
of the most
amazing things in my life that i get to
do a podcast which of course needs money
to to fuel and i have a sponsor like you
who i genuinely believe is going to help
every single person
who starts their heel journey change
their life because this podcast the
central intention of this podcast is to
help people live better lives and we get
to sit here and i get to promote to you
a product which has not only helped me
change my life but it's going to help
millions of people and is helping
millions of people live a nutritionally
complete life it's so it's such an
incredible product and for me the reason
why it's incredible it is because it
gives me my protein it gives me my
vitamins minerals it's plant-based it's
low in sugar
free it does all of that in a small
drink that tastes good there are other
products there's foods there's the hot
and savory collection many other things
but for me
this ready to drink is the absolute
saviour of my diet throughout the week
where i'm moving at such pace
look i don't want to labor the point but
if you haven't tried you'll give it a
try and if you do
tag me instagram wherever you try it
give me a tag anyway
back to the podcast
we moved forward to covid yeah which was
you know you get appointed as being the
health minister when a pandemic rolls in
i know i remember i remember seeing the
um the the chinese publication on the
1st of
january so it's new year's day
and
i saw this thing on the inside pages of
one of the newspapers
um to say um the chinese just announced
that there's a
a new
uh disease
um and nobody knew we didn't know it was
a coronavirus it might have been a flu
and nobody knew whether it was serious
or not but i remember thinking
well maybe this is it
but i didn't really think it was until
um
until a couple of weeks later when was
that that because i you know i was
reading through all of the minutes from
your sage meetings to try and understand
the the kind of phases of yeah because i
listen i run business right and we have
crises and chaos all those things yeah
there's various stages you go through of
trying to understand exactly what this
is and then
how you know how impactful it's going to
be yeah and then what we should be doing
yeah i kind of ran through all of that
so when in your view did you start to
realize that
this wasn't just a
of january so the chinese published the
sequence of the genome of the of the
virus so we then knew it was a
coronavirus um that was bad news right
because we had a stockpile of flu
vaccine
uh for this sort of emergency if it had
been a flu
um and the fact that it was a
coronavirus and spreading this rapidly
in china was bad news
and then
at that point
i remember chris witty saying to me is
50 50.
something this contagious either they
can
hold it in china
or if it gets out of china it's going to
go global
so we were by the end of january we were
on to
developing the vaccine for instance
and
trying to get the testing system up and
running and then we had this surreal
month during february
when
nobody else was sort of thinking that
this was a big thing and we still
thought it was 50 50 but 50 chance of a
global pandemic is you know very very
bad
and
we were i remember standing next to the
speakers chair in the house of commons
for a pmqs
watching
every single question was about
something else and nobody asked a
question about what became known as
covid and i remember thinking at the end
of the session the end of half hour
every single question that has been
asked is totally irrelevant because
it's all about other things
and
we've got this one fact in china
and it is
it's totally dominant why weren't you
raising the bell
i was i was giving statements to
parliament and what have you and we were
preparing
inside government for what needed to
happen so at the end of january
uh
jvt came and said
um i said how long will it take to get a
vaccine he said well normally it would
take five years
but we think we can do it in a year to
18 months
in january yeah if everything goes well
and i said your mission is to have a
vaccine by christmas and we
he he and the team that we built pulled
it off
um so we were getting things
moving and then it was when we saw the
pictures from italy do you remember the
you know that was the moment
that i knew it was global and that was
what month that was the end of february
february yeah it was the end of february
half term because everything was calm at
this point we were watching it happen
overseas i mean like i remember this the
china scenes yeah everyone was kind of
calm about it oh china are having a
problem that's kind of how it felt and
then the italy moment was was terrifying
yeah that was the moment when it was
obvious it was coming right um and um i
remember having a call that uh my my my
german opposite number who i got you
know became very close to
he phoned me up he said have you seen
these pictures out of italy i was like
yeah he's like this is it
and it's like yeah this is it
um so that was the end of yeah that was
the end of february
but still in march there was a lot of
confusion in those stage minutes about
what to do yeah about what was going to
happen yeah could do could we stop it
yeah
complete lack of data that's the that
was the problem total positive data um
we had a um we didn't have a testing
regime we had to build that from scratch
uh and so you didn't know how many
people had it
um we didn't know the characteristics of
the disease uh we didn't know what the
um
we didn't know what you know what the
symptoms were largely because the
symptoms of copings are so varied that
they didn't have a full symptom less
list one of the things that we didn't
know for ages which we now take for
granted knowing is how many people have
had it and have got the antibodies there
was a big debate after the first peak
of um
some people saying
uh they're optimists like me but it
turns out far far too optimistic right
saying oh yeah three quarters of people
must have had it by now so basically
we're fine
uh and we're through it and then
so i got a survey done
taking people's blood
and got the
got a representative sample it took ages
to get this thing up and running
and
we eventually got the data through
that said that something like
in london 15 of people had had it and
outside london it was under five it's
like christ that means almost nobody's
had it and still we've had all these
deaths
and that means you know that was the
moment we knew we had a major problem
because there was no way through this
other than the vaccine and sage at this
point and the meetings that you're
having there there's kind of this
resignation that it is going to just
wipe through the population but but the
issue is the objective is now just to
try and stop it smashing the nhs
basically yeah so
what happened was you know we saw those
predictions of the
uh the reasonable worst case scenario
but the big problem was we were going up
the reasonable worst case scenario
quickly you know and i remember
i remember of course i remember the the
day that the first person in the uk um
dived of covid but but i remember the
day
that oddly something like the 32nd
person died
and
it's a funny to say that number but it's
a there's a reason for it i was sitting
on the side of my bath at home
and i got the news that we'd had 30 32
deaths and suddenly there was a this
isn't you know one person to him we've
got a protocol of how you manage that
um
terrible as that is this is like
big numbers and it was a big jump in the
number and i knew that that that number
was going to get bigger
and the worst period the the most um
sort of frightening period of the whole
thing
was after we'd done the lockdown
we'd pulled every lever we could
so i remember sitting in the cabinet
room and saying
we're going to have to tell people to
stop all unavoidable social contact
and you probably remember
you know that being said
and
um
the the really frightening time was
after we'd done all those things brought
in the lock down we'd done everything
right and if this disease had carried on
going up there was there was absolutely
nothing more we could do we'd shut the
schools we'd shut hospitalized yeah we'd
pulled
yeah we'd set out at the start of march
a a set of options of levers that we
could pull to try to stop this thing
and by the middle of march we pulled
every lever
and it was a um and so the next two
weeks as the numbers carried on going up
they carried on going up for about 10
days because of the incubation period
that was that was
that was really scary and then and then
and then they started to turn and then
we knew we could get this thing under
the criticism leveled at the uk is that
we were the last like major western
country to pull those leaves levers
you've described in mid-march when you
look through the minutes there is just
like several weeks of like con confusion
and indecision and obviously in those
weeks as you've described there yeah
what you didn't from what i've seen in
the minutes and subsequent interviews is
what you didn't know was the speed of
transmission that was going on yeah and
obviously because of that 14-day death
delay delay yeah so so it's funny that
i'm you know it's funny that the
previous conversation we had was about
how you should have the experts making
the decisions yeah the truth is we
didn't have the
the experts didn't have the data either
so these were difficult calls actually
in terms of
where we were on the curve
we pulled the levers ahead of other
countries because we were a bit behind
italy and and um uh uh
spain
um
but the um yeah
so spain and spain france and italy went
into lockdown on the 9th of march yeah
but we
reckoned that we were several weeks
behind them in terms of the progress of
the virus that it as in it had come to
those countries first and then from them
to us but either way and that was wrong
the big picture we were much closer
to them than than than we were being
than the best estimate right by these by
the best people who were in sage there's
the scientists
and
you know what it felt like was
this is an enormous call
so the costs of action are huge
the costs of inaction are also huge
so you you know we knew when we were
sitting around the cabinet table making
these decisions that the the the balance
between these two was an enormous
enormous
unknown so in a with an unprecedented
virus with very little data
we were essentially
you know
doing these things that were so we knew
we were very it were going to be very
damaging if you think about the story
about i
i told earlier about coming in i i came
into politics partly because i had this
searing formulative experience of
something completely outside of our
control nearly knocking out the
livelihood of my family right and here i
am
participating in decisions that were
going to have
a more devastating impact on on
businesses
and and and people
who rely on social contact in order to
to survive and thrive so we were hugely
aware of the of the pain that would come
from the decisions as well as the pain
that would come from
from delay and the other thing that we
didn't know was how the public would
react
right and this is there there's an
optimistic story which is the public
were amazing
you know and and the advice that we were
getting was we're not sure whether the
public will will will put up with
lockdown for very long
um and so you've got to time the period
of lockdown actually the public were
amazing once you explained that you know
there's a serious problem
um we're all going to have to
uh do something
it's going to be uncomfortable but we'll
get through it together and the public
were amazing obviously with italy spain
and france looking down first there was
also a bit of a case study as to how
publics will react yeah if presented in
a certain way yeah um to the lockdowns
the
because we were
later in locking down people
if you look at the numbers they say that
there's about 20 if we'd lock down a
week earlier 21 000 people would still
be alive from that first wave
when you hear that yeah
how does that how does that sound and
feel and also around that time boris
johnson goes and does that interview and
references one of the options being
taken on the chin
and then in hindsight how does that all
feel for you personally
that thought that one week earlier we
could have saved 21 000 lives yeah um
it's
obviously it's something i'll i'll
always think about
um
you know
if i search for what i really believe
about that and the honest truth is the
honest truth is
that
we didn't know
and of course
you know hindsight is a wonderful thing
and
it was about it was judgments based on
on on these you know this the
the balance of these two scales
um
and um
i think that
whenever you go through a period of
history
ultimately it's about learning from it
you know you've got to make sure
that that if this if a pandemic you know
disease happens again we'll be far
better prepared and i think that the i
think the far east was far
better prepared because they'd been
through
murders and stars and and um
honestly that how i feel is like i
really wish we'd known then what we knew
now
what if you in hindsight then because
we're playing games of hindsight now
which are as they say it's 2020 but what
are when you look back honestly at the
decisions that were made and how you got
the data and the way that the meetings
were handled with sage and all of these
and ultimately what led to these
decisions
what in hindsight which is a wonderful
thing that we can only deploy in in the
past yeah in hindsight what do you think
were the mistakes
all the areas where we could have done
better in the decision making how we got
the information and all those things
what were those mistakes in hindsight
well um
you know we made there were some
mistakes that we made in terms of the
measures yeah how they were brought in
as in not hard enough or
just you know
just details about the things that
really really matter to people
um i'll give you one example um funerals
we brought in rules saying that six
people could go to a
funeral i think it was
very very restrictive
but for some people especially people
who were shielding
the rules were interpreted as
in some cases even the spouse shouldn't
go to the funeral if they were shielding
now that was that was terrible i
remember watching that
the film of a young boy who died
who was
buried by people in hazmat suits without
his parents there and
you know that was just
awful
and
you know you listen to that right and we
changed the rules and made it made it
clear
so you know that was a that was all the
time i think you know all the time we
were on the lookout for
okay what do we need to be doing
differently because it was unprecedented
and
there was a um
and
you know in hindsight some of it looks
like these were sort of hard and fast
and obvious decisions they weren't
obvious decisions at all and we were
constantly sort of questioning ourselves
uh in terms of um in terms of whether we
got the judgment right what was your
life like in that time oh yeah
well i i so my alarm went off at six
o'clock every morning
and um
i'd um
you know i basically had about
uh half an hour with the kids in the
morning
and then
uh i'd get picked up at
7 30 maybe seven o'clock
and
uh and then and then work i was just you
know unbelievable um until about
about midnight and i you know what my my
permanent secretary chris wernwell at
the start said
this is not going to be over in a in a
couple of weeks right you've got to get
we've all got to get ourselves into a
position where we can just keep going
this is a marathon not a sprint
and um
um and there was a um
a weekend
basically meant that we didn't start
work till about nine
and so that was the you know that was
the
the time off so to speak and that
it was like that for three or four
months
during that what about your mental
health position because i yeah you know
because
that feeling that going home every day
without feeling that my decisions could
sway as we saw negatively in this case
you know 21 million 21 000 lives yeah
better for worse and ultimately you know
160 000 people died yeah you're going
home with that every day yeah with that
thought that you're just the decisions
you're making now as a health secretary
yeah are life and death yeah how do you
relax how did you yeah i think that's
really relaxation i got to through
exercise
um
but the um
in the health department the sense was a
total sense of mission
um
and i've never been in the military but
some people say this is what it's like
when you're on a military operation as
well
um as in
there was
a focus over how to optimize how we
could make decisions you know of course
there were sleepless nights but
really we thought you know when we had
some you know chris whittie himself is a
brilliant advisor on how to keep
yourself you know personally in the
um
in the zone so the the sense of mission
that we were trying to solve something
that was incredibly difficult as best as
we could
um was very very strong in that period
did you have anxiety
it depends what you mean by anxiety of
course i was anxious about every you
know all these big decisions about that
awful sense of nervousness that you know
can be crippling at times you know that
yeah but it was yes up to the but not
about i you know i didn't i didn't find
it i i didn't find it crippling i found
it motivating
do you know when i say anxiety do you
know what i mean
i mean there's the the kind of phrase of
describing something as being an anxious
situation but then actually suffering
with anxiety yeah not not in a medical i
didn't feel that in a medical sense i
basically felt like i got up in the
morning
and i
did my level best
and then i went to sleep and then i woke
up and repeated the exercise and that
for me that was the only way to get
through it without sort of collapsing in
a hoop if you'd known that a pandemic
would roll in would you have avoided
that health secretary job
be honest with me
i don't know
i don't know that's a great question
someone's got to do it
would you have
if you knew that that situation was
covered if i knew this situation was
coming there's about 100 things i'd
immediately done right we would have no
no no i mean would you put yourself
in that role if you knew that if if i
said now there's a pandemic coming next
week do you want the job of being
healthy such a what if questions but i
would answer it the honest truth is yes
you would take it yeah okay
because someone's going to make the
decisions
okay so one of the one of you know what
do you know what the the overriding
stats is um
that i'm trying to articulate not
particularly well is a sense of this
sense of duty
right when the really bad stuff happens
and and you're in the job you've got to
stand up and be counted
one of the decisions that was made was
and ultimately criticizes this whole
care home yeah stuff what's your view on
that before yeah so so okay this is a
really good example of um
the the the
of of
of learning from what you're seeing on
the ground so the criticism runs that
um the nhs made a decision to get people
out of hospitals because we needed
hospital space
and send them into care homes and that
took covid with them and a lot of people
died
um that criticism is wrong
but there's a different criticism which
is more accurate
the re the reason that's wrong is um too
fond there's been a piece of work that's
a piece of uh analysis that's done
that's shown that approximately two
percent of the
uh infections that got into care homes
were from that route
the um and the reason for that is that
when those people went into the care
homes they were they then isolated in
the care homes
because they weren't tested because the
test didn't exist now i wish to god that
the tests had existed and would you know
that was a big part of my life trying to
build this testing system um but they
they didn't exist and most of those
people who left hospital actually went
home not into not into care homes
the truth is
that the peak in the care homes came
about a month later
so the facts don't even stack up this
narrative but they've been there's you
know there's a few false narratives that
have got going about the pandemic and
that's one of them
the truth is and we couldn't say it we
didn't want to say it at the time
because we didn't want to demotivate
people but the truth is that the main
route of
the virus getting into care homes sadly
was from staff because staff live in the
community and this disease was rife in
the community but i didn't want to stand
at that podium and give the impression i
was blaming the staff
the thing that we then did was we
changed the rules so you could not let
work in more than one care home
and in the second wave the number of
deaths in cairns was far far lower and
we had the testing so actually the what
we needed to have done was do the do the
poli the staff movement policy much
earlier
and we hadn't
we hadn't spotted that that was the
route
um and so you know there's an inquiry
that will come and go through all these
things and i'm actually looking forward
to it because there's a whole series of
points where we've got to make sure we
learn the right lesson
and then there's a couple of other
things that are upper there that you
know just aren't true and need to be
like this whole yeah we talked about
criticism as a politician right one of
the things i've been criticized for is
for giving a contract to the local pub
landlord right i don't know whether
you've read that story yeah i've heard
all of that stuff yeah it's just not
true we'll talk about that i want to
just because the the point on the care
home yeah it's good you so you've
answered one of my points there which
was about that whole rumor that people
were being released from the nhs into
care homes and that was causing issues
the thing that that i saw from the sage
minutes was that on the roughly the 10th
of march which was fairly early in all
of this yeah sage did say that there
should be special policy consideration
given to care homes yes and various
types of types of retirement communities
yes presumably you had the data at that
point that said elderly people were
being disproportionately affected by so
around the 10th of march yeah
but
there should probably should have been
an action taken yeah and then in the
sage minutes you don't really see care
homes or retirement communities
mentioned again until a month later
when there's been serious death in care
homes i think people going into care
homes were 10 times more likely to die
than if they'd just gone gone home
because of the because of the more than
10 times more likely to i think at the
peak of the pandemic the first wave that
they were 17 times more likely to die in
a care home than
had they just gone home to live with you
know in a private home yeah but that's
because there's lots of reasons for that
you've got to unpack it so firstly it is
the most vulnerable people who live in
care homes so their their vulnerability
to the disease is much greater secondly
you know the nature of care homes is
obviously that the disease can spread
more easily and every european country
had this problem but the broader point
about the sage minutes um
around that time
um
action was taken
but we didn't get to the policy that i
think had the best impact which was the
stopping people from working in more
than one care home for several months
afterwards yes and if
we'd if we'd known that that was going
to be the thing that would say stop it
as much as it did obviously we would
have done that
um we would have done that earlier but
but again it comes down to uh to not
knowing yeah and i i guess
this is a point of judgment hindsight
has revealed that that was a mistake
some countries got it right new york
didn't get it right either i mean but
other countries did get that you know
the other thing we were worried about so
we were worried about a different
problem that didn't happen
and
sometimes this you know
it's important
to think about at the time the things we
were worrying about so
in spain
a whole care home full of elderly people
had died because the staff had all gone
home
so we were also worried about making
sure that the care homes remained
staffed because people in care homes die
if the staff aren't there
so
thankfully that never happened but we
were worried about the the the care the
you know we were worried about the
opposite problem at the same time and um
and and you know thankfully we avoided
one
but but the other one came to pass do
you look back on that that decision in
particular because that's one of the big
criticisms that a lot of people level at
the um handling of the the process do
you look back at that as a another
mistake in hindsight
because you you as you say you were
trying to make the best decision on
balance yeah right i i know i know for
sure and that would you've done
differently but yeah what
so on this foresight hindsight thing i
know for sure
that
i did my best
and i know that the team around me
worked with
you know did
work with the right motives to get
through as best we could
the um
the importance of learning how best to
handle this situation
for god forbid if it happens again
is absolutely vital
but i worry as much about learning the
wrong lessons as learning the right
lessons so that's why it's important
that we have this sort of discussion
about about the care homes in particular
to to make sure that just because
something is in the narrative it doesn't
necessarily mean it's true
uh without doubt if i'd known then what
i know now
we would have brought in the staff
movement rule much earlier in fact do
you know what you should probably have
it in normal times as well because lots
of people die each year in
fluent care homes and
you know so the and the processes of how
flu gets into a care home are probably
the same
as covid because it's just another
communicable disease when people like
mark the success of um our handling of
the pandemic one of the ways that they
choose to do it is to compare it to
other countries and in that first wave
in particular our deaths were just so
much higher than the comparable
countries
so does is that not an indicator that we
messed up or that we got it or that our
judgment calls
turned out to be the wrong ones
a combination of a combination of things
right combination of things like the
timing of the decisions
locked down
um the obesity of our nation compared to
others is one other factor
um one of the factors that um the
experts think is a cause is that
lots of people
travel
from all over the uk to spain and italy
during that half term and so it was
brought back
and seeded across the whole country
whereas some other countries like france
had it very badly in
a couple of cities but didn't have the
spread in the way we did so there's some
things that are essentially you know
just
just facts of life that were outside
anybody's control
obviously that's not
you know what you're getting at and it's
not the stuff that really affects how i
think about it because it's the it's the
active decisions that
we also need to you know we need to go
through and learn from
so would you
that's what i'm saying is
is that the large number of deaths that
we had versus other countries
a
indicator that we made poor decisions in
that first wave well now you see stephen
you're getting into gotcha questions no
i genuinely cause because we're going to
go on to the good stuff right we're
going to get into the fact that we're
out of lockdown for everybody else so
the but the way the reason i i reacted
that way is that is that it is
self-evident and obvious
that
you've got to improve decisions and
learn from them and the best and the
best proof point of this
and the best um sort of it's obvious
from anybody who's running any
organization is you constantly got to be
asking was that the best decision
and
part of leadership
is to allow your team
to
essentially learn from and change their
decisions not stay stuck with them just
because that's the decision that we took
and
in the second and subsequent waves
we have done relatively better
internationally so how i feel about all
that is i feel um i feel sad that the
performance in the first half
if you like was not as good as it could
have been okay that answers the question
and then i feel
and i but i feel pleased
that we learned quite a few things and
in a way you know we did better second
time round yeah but the thing i felt at
the time and this is true in any
organization i've been in
is that if you want people to perform at
their best
they have to know that if they screw up
they're not going to get shouted at the
question is not who did that it's how do
we fix it yeah and that was a that
attitude was a big part of
um of of how things you know we managed
to get better you know testing is
another example right testing first it
was
you know it was far we didn't have any
we built it as fast as we could
that needed to go much faster by this
christmas the americans were saying why
can't we have a testing system like uh
like the uk you know and my view is that
uh dido harding did an amazing job
but every time we had a screw-up the
question that we asked was how do we fix
it not whose fault is it did you
actually think that was got your
question because do you think do you
think i'm the type of person that would
sit here i don't think you are which is
why i called you out on it because yeah
because it's every question i ask is
honestly honestly
genuine yeah because and then you're
right there's so many things that we did
better than all of these other nations
and i'll be honest i'm sat here really
lucky that we're able to do this in
person right because of the decisions
that the uk took so you know what i
meant by uh gotcha is that you know the
the question of um
will you get the guy to say he that was
x screw up is a classic of the today
program i i base i might and actually
frankly makes some of the decision
making harder no i i i understand what
you're saying um my question was that is
the was the the increase in death at the
start
does is that evidence as people claim
that we made in hindsight because that's
what we have now in hindsight the
decisions were wrong and also there's
this other exacerbating factor which was
i mean the world health organization at
the time and even i tweeted it said that
there wasn't we couldn't wait for a
vaccine
they said that we that's what they said
they said we couldn't wait for a vaccine
because sometimes vaccines i mean
there's not a vaccine for sars still
sometimes they take five i never believe
so you so you you thought that was
always going to be a vaccine yeah and
and it's true that sometimes yeah in
number 10 he was basically the only
other person who agreed with me why did
he say the take on the chin thing
um because i use that he was i i
remember that he was he was actually
trying to argue against that he was
saying he was saying it comes down to
how difficult it is to communicate in
uncertainty he was saying some people
are saying we ought to take it on the
chin i don't agree with that i think we
need to act but
so one of the reasons it's hard to
communicate in politics and one of the
reasons it's hard to communicate
empathetically
is that you have to both have the actual
conversation
but also every single word you say can
be twisted will be taken and analyzed
for better or for worse and i don't hold
this against the media particularly but
they they will look at those words both
within the context and out of context
and so you know this is true of this
interview but i knew that coming into it
and have decided just to try to answer
the questions
um the um but that is part of
communication so i uh the the the
you know
boris saying that um
some people say we should just
wha i can't remember the exact words
but i don't think that's the way we
should do it instead we should do it
that way it was written up as boris
float's idea of taking it on chin well
he did float the idea but he then
immediately rejected it for a different
proposition i i did read the sage
minutes and to to his and your credit
you don't mention herd immunity as a as
the strategy to take forward in those
minutes correct from what i saw so
although that was a widespread narrative
right it's not that's actually what was
going on in the meeting the truth there
is that some people were pushing the
herd immunity idea right and then um
the k it came it came it bubbled up and
came to a head yeah and
i had i went out and
you killed it so i was like no we are
not doing that so you you knew that a
vaccine was going to be i had at first
it was faith right at first it was faith
and it gradually became more and more
real
um and i just i i
i knew that we'd got a vaccine for ebola
right and the the oxford vaccine
actually comes from the work several
years before to get an ebola vaccine
and
i had i just had this belief
and maybe it's because i'm an optimist
once the data came out in about may that
showed that only you know this tiny
proportion of the public had
had antibodies and had had exposure and
therefore it was obvious and
categorically impossible to get to
the levels of antibodies you need across
society without a
huge amount of suffering and death um
i.e the people who'd been promoting herd
immunity were now
evidently and scientifically wrong it
wasn't just it was a bad idea it was
provably a bad idea
once we got to that point there was only
one way out and that was a vaccine and
you know i believe in the power of human
ingenuity and i
believed in the team in oxford um and i
also thought that when the whole world
is searching for something
then
then
somebody was gonna get it right and so
we brought in
um people to to go and buy from around
the world like like kate bingham and we
took this attitude which was sure we
backed the british one but we absolutely
we're going shopping as well right and
and money is no object um and um and and
and that's what we did and thank god we
did it was there a tipping point where
because in the stage minutes there's
this there's this understanding that
this is going to go through the
population yeah really the central
objective has to be to protect the nhs
and then was there a tipping point where
you realized the vaccine was going to
come and it was going to come quickly
yeah so the strategy then has to go to
like a the vaccine's on its way so now
it's about actually limiting death as
well so it was once we found out that um
that
only a small proportion of the
population had had it
it was obvious from then on that the
only way out was through a vaccine and
therefore the policy became
to suppress the virus until a vaccine
makes us safe and i then repeated that
all the way through the summer the
autumn and in the autumn i was arguing
for
you know to keep this thing under
control because the vaccine's around the
corner and people were briefing against
me that no you know hancock's the only
one who believes in the vaccine and it's
a running joke that there's only one
person who thinks the vaccine's gonna
happen and and and partly to try to stop
some of the complications that had
happened in testing i'd report i just
spoke directly to the prime minister on
this one and didn't go through his then
advisors in number 10.
and and and it and it came good we have
a brand new sponsor for the podcast and
it's a brand called crafted as you can
see on the table in front of me if
you're watching this on youtube crafted
our brand that sell really meaningful
affordable men's jewelry and i've been a
crafted customer i think for about three
years now and all of the pieces that
craft that have created have deeper
meaning the piece of jewelry i wear the
most i want to introduce you to the
pieces and why i wear them is this sand
timer unsurprising and the thing for me
about sand timer is it's probably the
most clear reminder that our time here
on earth is finite and when you live in
such a way where you can literally see
your time pouring away and you realize
that it is scarce and that we're not all
here forever you start to make better
decisions you stop worrying about
pettiness and trivialities that consume
our lives i always have this crafted
sand timer around my neck as a reminder
of that and this is why i wanted crafted
to sponsor this podcast because i can
use their meaningful jewelry
every episode to deliver a meaningful
message
quick one as many of you know i've been
trying to make my life a little bit more
sustainable as it relates to energy ever
since i sold my range over sport and
bought an electric bicycle and my energy
as a sponsor of this podcast one of the
brands that make that transition much
much easier they are at the forefront of
british renewable ecosmart technology
and their products are really really
changing the game if you're on youtube
you can see what i'm holding in my hand
this is called the eddie right it's the
uk's number one solar powered diverter
so what is a solar diverter it's a
device for people like you and me that
means you can divert your excess energy
back into your home rather than back
into the grid which will save you power
and money it's super user friendly and
easy to install and you can control it
using the my energy app on your phone to
find out more about this product and
more products like it that will help you
make that sustainable transition head
over to myenergy.com and um i highly
recommend you check out the eddie it's
um it's a real game changer for a
product and one that i'm going to be
installing in my home soon
you talked about the some of the
procurement rumors there yeah one of
them particularly that you meant you
wanted to mention about a pub a friend
that runs a publishing or something yeah
so so i mean this is an example of why
of how you need to go through these
things properly and how narratives can
sort of spin out of control
and this is true on social media and
which you're a great expert in but it's
also true in the mainstream media
so for some reason that i that is lost
in the midst of time some of the papers
got the idea
that
the landlord in the village that i
had previously lived in in suffolk
um who had then gone on to
run this factory
had got a contract that i had given him
and you know it was on the front page of
the guardian for several days and it was
a and and it's just all it's not true he
didn't have a contract with the
department he didn't have a contract
with the nhs um he yes he he flipped his
factory to making those little plastic
tubes
uh you know the ones that you um stick
your test thing into but we needed
millions of these things and somebody
had to
i didn't have anything to do with the
contracting arrangements because he he
was a subcontractor to another business
so there's no way that we i mean it's
just a total
it's a total nonsense and
so
in in a stressed period like a pandemic
a lot of conspiracy theories got going
this was one of them been loads on on
vaccines from the anti-vaxxers and
dealing so you've got to deal with that
misinformation at the same time as
trying to make the best decisions as you
can and that is one of the that is one
of the hardest things to wrestle with in
in terms of how we communicate
the um the rumor around that time was
that he'd sent your whatsapp message and
you'd like forwarded him on to someone
and that led to him getting a
a deal yeah so he he i mean these
whatsapps have been been published under
foi the what was about something
incredibly banal it was about
standardizing the size of these tubes
across different suppliers
so that they could be made more
efficiently i mean like a really in the
weeds a bit of policy right and i just
pinged this on to the people i mean
it was okay
it was at a level of detail about eight
below where i was okay um operating
there was
in 2000 may 2021
there was there's some minor inadvertent
breach because you held shares in a firm
that had got a contract no no so that's
not true either there you go i mean this
is um i i was i was given some shares in
my sister's company right
um
and they had a contract
an existing contract with the welsh nhs
right and i wasn't responsible for the
welsh nhs so it's another example are
you familiar with that rumor yeah of
course of course yeah i mean i have to i
have to deal with the these rumors all
the time and sometimes people stand up
in parliament and say it and you just
have to hit it on the head every time it
comes up it's just not true but but
there's an underlying problem which is
that you know the people working to save
lives in this period were working
incredibly hard
to just deliver that as best as they
could and all the people who now
try to sort of say oh no no you were
trying to contract for business it's
just all total rubbish i mean you can't
there is no other description of it on
the eighth i think it was the eighth of
december it was yeah where that that
first vaccine was administered and you
went on tv and got very you cried i did
yeah yeah yeah talk to me about that day
and those feelings and what was going
through your mind well
that was it was incredibly emotional
it was because
because we'd put everything into this
and the very first vaccine
down the track so to speak had worked
right we bought six vaccines
uh including the oxford one
um actually one of them only got
approved about two weeks ago and imagine
if
you know imagine if that and that had
been
the case for all six
so the fact that the very first one
sailed through and has worked
brilliantly
and then the oxford one like the home
the home um
uh vaccine that also has gone
brilliantly although you know there was
a load of noise in the politics of it
and the europeans getting shirty but
on a clinical basis has been amazing um
and um
so on the 8th of december
the first person receives it and this is
the way out of this terrible situation
that we're all in
and all these people had died
and i knew that
science was going to save us
but that wasn't the worst you know that
was
then the problem was at the same time
you know
we were having the second wave getting
really big so it was a really mixed
period because we had the the the joy
that the vaccine was working but at the
same time you know cases growing and um
i was on i was on good morning britain
um and i hadn't seen the image you know
the video of margaret keenan getting i'm
sure you're thinking of it now right we
can all remember it and i had but i
hadn't seen that image
and they showed the image
and i completely lost it and i was i was
in floods of tears and totally lost
control of my
um
of my my body and my voice
um and then i tried to pull it together
and they said in my ear you know we're
coming back to him five
and um
and i tried to pull it together i just
about got it together and then started
talking to i think it was piers morgan
again
and on twitter they were like this guy's
making it up he's not authentic he was
just trying to cry the honest truth was
if they'd come back to me like five
seconds earlier i would have been in a
complete mess and i was trying to hold
myself together and maybe maybe as
politicians would do that too often i
was maybe i should have just been more
relaxed about it because i got a load of
abuse for looking inauthentic because i
was trying to sort of be professional
and um
and and
not cry well for me that was actually
the first time that i thought you you
did have empathy right i know that right
because
because i've said on this podcast which
you've listened to i said that i thought
you were an emotionless robot yeah and i
genuinely outrage
i think jacinda in new zealand
has felt much more i don't know like
human and emotional and i think that
gives gives me as a muggle as a normal
person yeah a sense that they understand
me so when i see politicians being a bit
straight-faced and tough yeah yeah you
know he was really good at that barack
obama he would cry after sandy hook and
these these kids shootings
he would just cry he would stand for the
nation and he would cry and it made me
realize that he felt the same way that i
did whereas i the reason i said you were
i thought you were an emotionless robot
and i know you heard it
was because i'd never seen that and part
of the reason i'd be honest and i've got
to be fair part of the reason i've never
seen that is because you're put in
situations where they are trying to
always just get you like five or ten
minutes well that's that's part of it
you're defensive yeah so one of the
things i've learned
without a shadow of a doubt is that
you've just
you've got to
um you've just got to let that show and
i fin you know as a
i find that
um
i find it hard
um
and um
you've just got to let that emotion show
more um and and and just just try to be
just trying to say it as you feel it
um the podium doesn't help
all right the very formal communication
method you know to union jack's oak
background um the so the podium doesn't
always help to because it puts that a
barrier in place but then you mentioned
barack obama and you know he's still a
bit sort of the podium wasn't a problem
for him
but he's an extraordinary communicator
right he is extraordinary you said you
find it hard to show that emotion yeah
because the my the natural instinct when
you're under especially when you're
under pressure in questioning is to say
is to sort of
uh
go
go alpha male 1 this isn't always the
best answer
i think that is a problem with politics
i think that
um i think that the political leaders
that probably will end up doing really
well and i don't honestly i don't see
this on either side of the aisle but you
know because because i'm relaxed now and
the way that we're talking there'll
probably be something on mail online
tomorrow you know hancock's in such and
such uh
screw up right
because that's how i don't know what it
is i mean we've been talking for so long
but i i there is there will be um that
is how the media reacts and so you and
so once you once you once you're kind of
experienced in seeing that reaction
right you also then it tempers how you
talk so actually coming in one of the
reasons i wanted to come in and talk to
you
was because
i want to just talk freely
and i don't care if that is on you know
item 10 of the mail online tomorrow um
i'm just trying to answer the questions
as best i can and i i genuinely think
that is a better way of uh of of
communicating in politics and it's
definitely something that i've learned
yeah and that's something that i've just
seen to be so absent on both sides of
the aisle is
um a real sincere feeling of like
empathy and i think that makes
politicians feel like they're not us
yeah more distant yeah yeah yeah no and
there ends up being a language of
politics yeah and some people thinking
that they don't understand the code of
you know it's as if it's a code and you
know there is a um
and it's just
it's not helpful because it puts a a
barrier up i work really hard at trying
to do that that's why i was so upset
when i heard you said something i really
respect
saying that i'm an emotional wreck or
whatever not emotional that's the
opposite so mention this robot right
thanks no you keep saying it
for me for me
it's important to say because it's what
i said and what i felt and and b it's
actually not just you it's generally
like the politics as as a whole i'm like
what i see in normal people is real
empathy and you're not you're not the
other thing is it's language yeah when
you when you when you do those
interviews on good morning britain
whatever yeah the language is not human
language it's very political and very
controlled i think pr training is
honestly a person in politics i worked
so hard not to do that but
political training but it is and it's
but it's in particular in response to
the aggressive questions right so you
you have not asked any aggressive
questions you've asked
insightful questions instead but when
you're on you know when you get uh
type question you give the
type answer yeah and that and i think
that's the issue is
how do we get to a state where
politicians go do you know what i know
that was a bit of a mistaken i know
heinz that's a wonderful thing you know
i'll tell you a story um the first time
i did any questions
uh when i was new in parliament um
i um
you go for a meal before you do any
questions
and um nigel farage's was on as well and
he had two pints
and i and i said to him like you have
two points before going on any questions
he said yes otherwise i can't talk
freely
and um i sat next to him and he managed
to get every single question to answer
to an answer about why awful why uh
europe was awful um and um
but he just absolutely you know he he
had a couple of bites and and he sounded
like he had a couple of pints now um i
don't you know whatever you think of his
politics
his ability to communicate in a relaxed
way and i remember thinking every time i
then saw him that was years before the
referendum every time i was like you've
obviously been drinking
i mean maybe maybe that's one way to but
i feel like it shouldn't have to i think
that the the people that are really
going to resonate with the public are
going to be the normal people that break
through without political pr training
yeah i think they'll resonate way more
with people i think obama was he felt
like one of them to me i know people
some people hate him and there's lots of
things with drones and whatever but
he felt like someone in the way he spoke
that i could relate to because i felt
the sincere emotion i don't really get
that from boris i don't necessarily feel
like boris has the same and then we go
back oh i just i disagree with that i
think that one of the reasons that boris
relates to people and people relate to
him
is because he he doesn't speak in
as you
call it political speak
one of the reasons he is such an
effective communicator whether you agree
with him or not um is that
uh it is that he he he doesn't play by
those rules
i i i understand what you're saying he
doesn't he didn't entirely feel like a
politician because come back to this
question about you know when we were
talking about at the start about
people's backgrounds yeah right
um
you know boris has a background as
different from
the voters of hartley paul as it's
possible to get
um but
you know
he can he can reach people
and i think that's actually i think he's
a good i put him in the barack obama
category actually yeah yeah for people
of a different politics yeah i would
because um he
because he's one of the few people who
who ca who really just um
will withstand the sort of criticism of
the of the next day's press in order to
try to actually say how he feels he's a
very very
um emotionally engaged person let's talk
about some of the stuff that you haven't
really been able to speak about at
length which was
in september 2020 we there was laws
established that well not laws but there
was guidance given to stop us engaging
within um having casual sex with people
outside of our household et cetera et
cetera
right
do you think you can answer ask the
question a little bit more
so in september 2020 you said this is
what you said um established couples
should be shouldn't be having sex there
should be boundaries you warned against
casual sex advising the public to stick
to well-established relationships and
joking i know i'm in an established
relationship and he told us to remember
the basics of hands face space
and and throughout that period hugging
was not i remember you saying that you
were looking for tugging your mum in
um the 17th of may and then all of this
stuff comes out with the sun the cctv
leak and everything in between yeah
there's a couple there's obviously we
just start again how would you like to
start it i don't mind it all of it
except the opening bit about casual
stuff okay fine i haven't had casual sex
with anybody okay fell in love with
somebody you weren't so we're gonna and
let me ask the question and you can
correct the question right so
the question yet okay let's do it right
so in september 2020
you said that when when asked that
established couples
um
only established couples should be
having sex there needs to be boundaries
you have to go no okay so
um those rules yeah were not in place
that was that was advice on tv yeah but
those rules were not in place when this
all this happened so there's a way that
we can do this bit of the conversation
but we cannot do it with you starting
talking about casual sex
can i ask the question you can ask a
question yeah let's ask a craftsman in a
reasonable way okay so i'm going to ask
you a question just
yeah this bit is really hard for me as
well i completely understand i
completely understand i actually haven't
asked the question yet
this is a preamble no no it's not i what
the point the point that's been leveled
at you is very simple it's that there's
a contradiction in what you said and how
you behaved that's what i'm that's what
i just totally
so can i ask that question yeah go for
it so the point that's been leveled at
you is there's a contradiction in how
you behaved yeah versus what the
guidance you were giving as health
secretary yes this is not a revelation i
mean this is a revelation exactly this
is what everyone's been saying hugging
was advised against you know distance
there was this whole hands face space
thing which we were all told to obey
yeah and couples
were um
when when asked you were said to stick
within well-established relationships
and you jokingly said i know i'm in an
established relationship then this cctv
stuff comes out yeah my question is you
know you talked earlier on about
funerals and people going through an
immense hardship
people say you were a contradiction yeah
what's your response to that
how do you how do you receive all of
that when everyone's this is what
everyone says this is not so yeah said
it for the first time no it's whatever
the whole world is saying at you this is
the central thing yeah and this is
ultimately why you resigned that is my
absolute that is my response so
i resigned because
i broke the social distancing guidelines
yeah
um by then they weren't actually rules
they weren't the law but that's not the
point the point is they were the
guidelines that i'd been proposing
and
you know
that happened because
i fell in love with somebody
and
you know i i've known gina for
more than half of my life and we first
actually worked together on student
radio um back in the oxford days
and um
i brought her into the department to
help with public communications in the
same way we brought loads of brilliant
people in who were experts in their
field
um
and
so we spent a lot of time together
ironically trying to
you know get me to be able to
communicate in a more emotionally
intelligent way
and and
and we fell in love
and
you know that's something that
that was completely outside of my
control
um
and i of course i
i regret the
you know the the pain that that's caused
and the very very very public nature you
know anybody who's been through this
knows how difficult it is how painful it
is
doing that in public is incredibly
painful
and um
but but you know
i fell in love with someone you did you
fall in love while working together yeah
okay so you know nobody you know we we
it all happened quite it all happened
quite quickly it actually happened after
this sort of thing stopped being after
the rules were lifted
but the guidance was still in place so
i'm not trying to claim that yeah i hold
no bitterness about about this because
um i broke the rules you know i fess up
i broke um the uh
the guidance
um
and
you know there were only two people
responsible for this
um
and
and ultimately that's why i resigned i i
took responsibility for my decision and
i resigned
um when that cctv stuff happens and i'm
not going to go into the details of
because i don't want to drag people into
this but i want to understand that how
that feels i can only imagine having
dealt with a pandemic and they're
getting this call from the sun yeah
they're about to leak something yeah i
i'd have i know this is the yeah this is
the i would i don't like i don't have
the words to describe yeah how that must
have all felt yeah but tell me
when you get that it was it was it was
awful
um
it was awful because
you know
we obviously knew what was going on
um
but we wanted to
uh to
to do this as unpainfully as possible
and by and by the release of those
images obviously that caused a huge
amount of pain
and
um
the uh and it was it's it's it's been i
mean anybody knows
anybody knows how difficult it is it you
know ending up ending a relationship
um and we have six children you know
it's it it's tough but you know
um
gina and i love each other very deeply
and um
where are we
seven eight months later
it gets it gets a bit easier with time
um and um
but i have no sort of
i don't hold it against anybody
because i was because you know we
were i take responsibility
have have they figured out where that
footage came from yeah you know so many
people ask me this question everyone's
asked the question and
um
you know my honest the honest feeling i
have in response to that question is i
just don't care
all right the
actually there's there's a funny story
which is that
um
the best i know
is that it was one of the um security
guards in the department um there's a
current ico investigation i don't know
any of the details of that investigation
i haven't got any inside information
other than that which is public however
the investigation
is based on a law data protection law
that i took through parliament into
which i personally put a journalistic
exemption
so
i'm i don't hold it against
um the against the journalists for
publishing it
um but obviously you know it was a very
serious data
data protection breach if you like the
thing that
we've learned
and i think all my other colleagues in
cabinet learned immediately is why did
you have a cctv in the secretary of
state's office obviously i didn't know
about it
um and because even who's in the office
is a is a
is an important fact and
a sensitive piece of information
um but all of that is by them by because
you know it is not the responsibility
of others
that
um that those social distancing
guidelines were broken you know that is
that is my responsibility and i took
responsibility for having done that you
took responsibility you went to boris
you said you know you'd apologize to him
and he considered the matter closed
and then
that's kind of where people thought it
had been left off but i think the
media noise and the pressure built and
eventually the narrative is that you
then resigned after
yeah after 20 48 hours it wasn't really
after the um it wasn't really the press
it was that
you know some people i really respect
got in contact and told me about things
that they had been not able to do like
well um like you know seeing dying
relatives
and
you know even though
it
you know and and
and i and i realized that it was
it was unsustainable
would you class that as the the worst
time of your life
being health secretary is not nearly as
difficult as
worrying about your
children
in a very public
divorce
um
undoubtedly this you know going through
that is undoubtedly the hardest thing
i've ever done
by a long long way
and as you go forward on that particular
situation what's your like strategy
because you've come from a home where
your parents weren't
they they they're broken up right yeah
what's your what's your strategy going
forward now to to try to mend to try to
be kind to try to
to try to
um
um
to try to make
you know on the fa obviously try to make
things better
um
and then on the professional side you
know i've got a
other things i'm interested in i
actually don't miss
this job as much as i expected right i'm
i actually i i'm really enjoying the
freedom of being on the back benches on
the professional side
and um i'm i'm you know i'm
i'm absolutely
you know
um
i'm absolutely in love with gina and
that that helps a bit
a lot of the um since you've departed
the front the front bench there's uh i
mean now there's there's a lot of party
gate stuff going on and yeah it's kind
of
almost reminiscent of your situation
because the the claim level that the
government is that there was a
contradiction there was all these
parties going on ten downing street
sounds like it was a bit of a nightclub
while the rest of the nation is were
locked down and obeying the rules yeah
you've not really been brought into that
as much i wasn't invited
you weren't invited but what's your
what's your take on that what's your
because i'm sure you get asked about
this well that's obviously very
difficult um but i do think you've got
to look at the
big picture of you know we're coming out
of the pandemic now and that's in part
in large part because of the
the big calls
but you resigned when when you had the
i'll be honest you had the decency to
say
right i have been a contradiction here
and i've let people down so you resigned
but
yeah but you know the prime minister has
so many other things on his plate as
well right he's got russia crimea and
he's got
uh the um you know getting out of the
pandemic that was a big call especially
the response to omicron getting that
right
and coming through first so he's got all
these other big things on his plate what
do you make of um i don't really have
much to talk about on this particular
but there's all this dominic cummings
stuff yeah he's become a very
interesting character a bit of a
whistleblower exposer type and you know
you're you've been supportive of boris
johnson pretty much the whole way even
as you say with the partygate stuff you
say we need to look at the bigger
picture but he released some text
messages that apparently are very
critical of you where boris said that
you you [ __ ] up ventilators and that
you're totally [ __ ] hopeless
yeah but remember at that time it's
subsequently transcribed that dominic
cummings was trying to get me fired
right and if you look at those text
exchanges they're like a dire tribe
against what i was up to right and um
that didn't actually reflect what was
going on so you know
boris has apologized for uh the way that
came over but actually if you um and for
you know for sending those messages but
actually if you look at it in context
the context is this guy was trying to
get me fired he sent a load of um
aggressive messages to the prime
minister the prime minister responded as
he did in a private setting never
expecting that to become public so um
i'm completely you know what
yeah there are there are there are
people who really want to fix things and
improve things in life
and um
and uh i'd rather be that type of person
speaking of fixing things yeah one of
the things you're really focused on
fixing at the moment and i've seen you
talk about this in parliament and in
several other places and a lot of the
interviews you're doing on twitter is
this issue of dyslexia in our country
tell me why
you alluded to earlier why this is
personal to you so so i was only
identified as dyslexic at university
and i know
despite really good teachers it would
have been so much easier for me because
before i was identified
i just thought i was stupid and and bad
at english and some people say you
shouldn't identify you know you
shouldn't tell
dyslexic because they're dyslexic
because then they'll be labeled but i
labeled myself as as as useless with
words and kids do that but still today
only one in five children are identified
at school
and i think this is
ridiculous especially in a world where
you can have online
assessments that can't then they can't
give you the formal diagnosis but they
can give you
the data that says this person's height
this child is highly unlikely to be
highly likely to be dyslexic
so i'm campaigning for that and in a way
it's one of these things that you know
now that i've got i can choose how i
spend my time as a backbencher this is
something i really care about i never
got round to doing it in government i
actually had assembled the little team
to push on this in the department for
health after the election before but
those people got moved on to have to
deal with the pandemic
so for me this is unfinished business
and for the you know
hundreds of thousands of dyslexic kids
out there
if i can
show them if i can show just one of them
that you can you can succeed
as a dyslexic person
and you can make it
as long as you get the support you need
as long as you get you know you get
identified um then then that will have
been worth it so it really really
matters to me and i'm sure we can make
loads of progress
when you when we talked about you having
this conversation with me here there was
i remember you saying there was things
that had been said that you wanted to
kind of have a chance to address and
rebuttal do you feel like you've had a
chance to address and rebuttal those
things
yeah i have um
i feel like you know because we've been
able to have a long conversation
you know there's a few of those um a few
things i've been able to explain
explain the thinking behind
um but i also hope that we can have a
proper
um debate about how this how the
pandemic side is dealt with properly in
the future
and um we can learn
[Music]
learn the lessons as best we can
and i think that's important every guest
in this podcast you know be aware of
this tradition leaves a question in the
diary of a ceo and i don't read it and i
swear on my i surround all my family
that i that i don't read it until i open
the book so forgive me if i takes me
some time to read the handwriting okay
here we go so the last guest on the
drivers here podcast left this question
for you
if you were lying on your deathbed what
three things would you want to have
achieved in life oh well that's great
three things three things you would want
to have achieved in your life pretty
ambitious um the number one is i want my
children to be happy and
and and have fulfilling lives
that is that is
undoubtedly number one the second is
that
i will have what i want to have a happy
and loving and
fulfilling
um
life and relationship
you know for the rest of my days
just
because of what's happened with gina
genie's actually here today it's worth
saying yeah
okay to say that yeah um because of
what's happened i'm guessing it's made
it's the scrutiny around because
relationships are hard already yeah but
the the context and the scrutiny around
that yeah what's happened must it can't
make it easier
we've been through a lot together okay
um
and
you know that's the
that's the joyous bit that's the easy
bit
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
of very difficult things that i have to
deal with um you know
and um
having fallen in love with gina is the
that's the easy bit
and the third one
and the third one
um i hope that i hope to have i mean
it's sort of both
it's so obvious
um but it and i'm gonna put some
i'm gonna try to answer it more
specifically um i hope to have
improve the country that i love
um and you know if for instance that is
making sure that every single dyslexic
child gets both the
the capability to read and write and
um be effective and the self-esteem that
comes with that
then that would be
that would be wonderful and i'm lucky to
have a platform
in parliament
um and through the fact that i'm
fairly well known to be able to to um to
try to affect change and that's what i
want to do
thank you thank you for both your time
because i know it's in a tremendous
demand but also thank you for choosing
to have this conversation here these
conversations aren't easy so it's often
easy to
easier to avoid them and you know we
talked about the importance of emotion
and relatability in politics so i want
to thank you for taking the time to have
a conversation where you didn't set any
restrictions on me my line of
questioning at all and you let me ask
the questions which as a quite naive
person who isn't politic and really
political
um would have and i think that's a
credit to you and i i thank you for that
and um yeah well thanks for giving me
the chance i don't think you're naive at
all you're self-knowing and
yeah that's the most important thing to
know well thank you
[Music]